so it's been over six weeks since the
parklands shooting during that time
we've seen marches town halls and media
spectacles both great and small heroes
and villains have been made
spokespersons anointed by cable news but
up until last Wednesday one person
didn't take part because he had been
shot five times as he tried to protect
his fellow classmates
Anthony Boras was released from the
hospital a teen no one had heard from
until now
he saved upwards of 20 students his
attorney read a statement from him which
criticized the sheriff Scott Israel and
others for knowing that this shooter was
bad news before the attack but still did
nothing both of you failed us students
teachers and parents alike on so many
levels I want to ask you today to please
end your policy and agreement that you
will not arrest people committing crimes
in our school I want all of us to move
forward and the environment that allows
people like Nicholas Cruz to fall
through the cracks
you knew he was a problem years ago and
you did nothing
portes was too weak to talk but a
statement it was strong it reminded us
of the facts as criticism took us back
to what was revealed post attack the
tons of calls were made about the
shooter over the years that he had
emotional and disciplinary issues before
coming to Stoneman Douglas he was
abusive
still none took action the statement
also mentioned the promise program which
allows young criminals to avoid arrest
so the question is will this messenger
receive the same platform and spotlight
that others received it's a sad reality
in the world of cable news we have to
move on other tragedies await but
Anthony cannot move on which is why we
should press pause and listen to what
he's trying to tell us he cannot move on
the fact that Scott Israel can is a
disgrace yeah Kimberly we've heard very
little from Scott Israel the guy used to
seek the spotlight the Dow is under a
rock yeah because now the facts are
raining down on him and he cannot escape
the truth he tried to blame others
he demonized the NRA they analyzed
she blamed the people at the school he
blamed everybody except for accepting
responsibility for choices that he could
have made that would have prevented this
when you have authorities being called
30 different times to Cruz's house and
nobody does anything like what else do
you want someone to do in terms of
getting involved and trying to do
something to prevent future harm and
violence and Massacre and if you don't
learn from this situation you just focus
just on guns you're missing the point
and for this individual to still have a
job fact that he has not been suspended
and removed from his position to me is
just astonishing you know Danny he his
father also called out Israel for using
his son right after the shooting is a
photo opportunity and I apparently he
gave him is that $100 there was this
something very tapped him please keep
your money crass about this guy
absolutely and it's amazing that it
would be it will be interesting once
he's strong enough to talk to hear from
him about what kind of bravery it took
for him to be able to stand in front of
that gun yeah and take the bullets for
his students and I'm sure that they're
looking forward to him getting back to
school he's really a remarkable young
man very inspiring you know one he came
from Venezuela for this you know I mean
the irony of just leaving a place that
is known for incredible high crime and
you know when he wanted to be a
professional soccer player which isn't
gonna happen I hope it does happen I
hope he hope he recovers slowly I what
struck me from this it was very touching
was it I think this is something from
the heart of American students and he
says I just want to go to school yeah
and feel safe and I don't feel safe
right now going back to school is what
he said and to me that just struck me is
you know what this is no spin this is no
this is no not taking sighs this is a
young man and saying I think school
should be safe and I should feel
protected when I go to school I do think
it's about guns that I thought last week
in the shooting at YouTube you know easy
access to guns but from his perspective
even if we never settle the gun argument
in this country kids should be able to
feel safe in school and he makes a
strong compelling point by the way the
sheriff went to visit him at the
hospital
when you hear this from him don't think
oh this guy's just upset the president
hasn't paid attention he's saying this
despite that thank you for the visit but
you should have done more yeah exactly
he felt that it was a photo-op
what do you think what should be done
with Israel
well the Florida Department of that is
real not the good Israel yeah yeah the
Florida Department of Law Enforcement
has an open investigation they'll submit
their findings to Governor Rick Scott
and he can determine whether or not to
fire him or keep him and that should be
coming momentarily there's a great
ambush by a local reporter I believe for
me if you see that when Tracts sheriff
has reeled down and got in his face
pretty aggressively and said you know do
you accept any responsibility you know
what are you doing you have to answer to
some of this and he weaseled out of it
and he didn't look like he was in
control sheriff Israel and then he
fouled him and he was at a political
event later that day with all the stuff
going on in his community he's out there
hobnobbing with politicians and you know
raising money and politicking he just
has a lot of misplaced priorities like
the promise program got to get rid of it
ideally it's so you don't want to arrest
a lot of young black teenagers in high
school that's why the Obama
administration came in and pushed it
hard because you know it hurts their
ability to get into college and things
like that I get that but it can't be
blanket I mean this guy like you said in
the monologue was abusing students in
school was suspended was violent this is
a guy that had to have been arrested
because and that would have triggered
the inability to him purchasing a
firearm and and then you know for for
CNN to shine a spotlight away from
Israel and then towards the NRA does
such a disservice to the country and
they should be shining a spotlight on
things like what Rubio's doing and you
and I have talked about it the I think
it's something like the gun purchase
restraining order so you're not you're
balancing the ability to have the Second
Amendment with at the same time
protecting public safety if some guy
looks like he's a mental health nut you
know you have a judge judicata it and
then you take the gun away you know the
judges and the social service people
also didn't they blew it too okay
because I don't think it you know I
understand that you guys are so upset
with Israel but I'm just telling you
that there are lots of people who had
the
activity to act on mr. Cruz and didn't
write the FBI the locals and and what it
is rayul do he set up a perimeter
outside the school when the shooting was
going on and everything tells you you go
when you confront the shoe well that
wasn't Israel just so you know there's a
GoFundMe page and a lot of those you got
to check them out to make sure they're
real for his financial support for for
the family and it's already raised eight
hundred thousand dollars it's a legit
GoFundMe page you want to check it out
his body as a human shield to money
lives god bless them